looking for a second win
i mentioned 24 in the third innings 13
walks he's better than that and he knows
he
is one and two breaking ball did he go
strike three says ed hickox
fastball yes good clean inning for
burrills with a couple of strikeouts
yeah one and one for woody and the 316
earned run average he's had three
consecutive no decisions including his
last timeout
twins one two out of three at miller
park he was trying to return that favor
and take a couple here
and a bouncing ball another chance for
arcia
and woodruff has a three up three down
start to his
night 2-2 pitch to rosario change up
swung on and missed strikeout number one
for brandon woodruff
perfectly located at the bottom of the
strike zone and rosario
couldn't do much with it
2-2 pitch swing and a miss went back to
the change-up and samoa is gone
and the 3-2 and that is strike three
called
and the brewers dug out not happy pina
not happy they thought it was low
heard this collective groan jeffers
kicks out the leg
and the 2-2 he got him strike three
chased a breaking ball down to the zone
and jose so far is perfect through three
with six strikeouts and the batter is
now ill demarro vargas
driven to the gap in right center field
vargas has got a hit
and it'll be an extra base basic he's
got two
can he be the first on his way to third
he has the twins first
triple of the season
vargas at third base with a one out
triple here in the third inning
vargas's switch hitter with over three
as a right-hander
so far and two for two as a left-hander
so he's three for three as a left-hander
and now the big league
batting debut for ryan jefferson ah a
little nervous i'm sure but he got a
chance against that base hit
ground ball base head and jeffers in his
first
big league at bat it's an rbi single
how about that well they get that
baseball and they'll throw it out
so congratulations to ryan
first major league hit first major
league
run batted in twins laid one nothing
he's been pitching to the you know the
frame you see the box you see
the edges of the strike zone well that
one he just blew
by yellows he's you know ellich strikes
out for the second time for strikeout
number seven
[Music]
got him fastball buzzing the inside
corner
two strikeouts in each of four
no hit innings it looks over his
shoulder at the speedy rosario
from the stretch the pitch and this is
lined into left center
holt gonna have to play it off the wall
on a couple of bounces rosario's around
30. he's headed for home the relay for
marcia to the play
is in time
[Applause]
how many times have we seen arcia do it
holt hustled got to the ball off the
wall
hit the relay man and arcia did the rest
pina applied the tag
and boy is that a big big play for the
crew defensively
and he'll have a play as he goes into
the netting
oh nice work by eric sogard
as the brewers have a couple of
defensive plays that you
circle here in inning number four
so the bases are loaded with one away
jeffers to third kepler to second and
polanco reaching
three straight singles now after the
first hitter was retired
and he's setting up inside and a sinker
bounced over to arcia
here to run and the turn that's a double
play
six four three there's the ground ball
woodruff was looking for
didn't find the hole this time it found
arceum
for a big double play and that'll bring
up
vargas vargas going to make contact
there's a drive left center field
chasing at his hold
and ho will make a nice running catch
and everybody was advancing except the
runner at third rosario comes in from
third
twins have left runners on base all
night long and it's one of these games
where you feel like
maybe a chance to make them pay for that
smoke sends one the other way he hit it
well rosario back at the wall it's gone
and the brewers are on the board as
justin smoke goes opposite field
and it's a one-run game here at target
field yeah just
a different look anybody other than
burrills i mean barrios was unbelievable
tonight
they bring duffy in to get line drive to
left home run to left
that's a no for three tonight and now
two for 19 against milwaukee pitching
this year
high fly right center field back
and i think that's gone
a home run for nelson cruz just over the
tall
wall in right center field
a two-run home run
and the twins lead four to one
yeah he didn't know if that ball was
good to hit high off the wall it looks
like it just hit that
that home run mark well another bases
loaded situation now for the twins
all four up bases loaded walk adrianza
comes in from third
twins by four polanco one for four
tonight
chopped over the bag and down the line
two runs will score and polanco glides
into second with a two-run double
kind of an excuse me swing right there
that ball
with smoke playing off the line this
found its way right down that first
baseline
two more score and the twins break it
open here in the eighth inning
[Music]
right center field kepler ranging in and
the twins
finish off the brewers and finish a 5-2
home stand